I'm here to see through than ever the  world premiere of the new Metallica  movie dad has some lyrics here came to  get him signed I can't even comprehend  I'm going to see the greatest band ever  people should check it out in IMAX but  it's the only way to check out the  biggest fan  what you're actually Attica yeah every  single note on the narrator instances  that was a punch in the chest that was a  Metallica concert in a movie in IMAX  I saw them back in oh nine and this is  the same thing if not better than the  real thing  was by far the best sound I've heard in  a film  Elena contr from ever from that first  like guitar chord it just literally blew  your face  you